the great grand hill joins us where are
you today grant I am in Orlando Florida
and I was a driving range here at all
worth trying to make sure my golf game
is not like Charles Barkley's has
anybody helped you with your game you
know Tiger lived down there for a while
did he ever help you with your golf game
you know what I can I should have taken
advantage of Tiger living in the
neighborhood and maybe picking up some
tips from him but I didn't play golf
back then you know I I just started
about a year ago and and so it's been
good it's been an interesting process
but uh so I unfortunately I get a lot of
help and a lot of people in my ear which
is probably making my game a little bit
worse but it's fun I enjoy it my swing
is better than Charles for the record
and I wish I picked it up earlier
because I never thought I was that guy
that thought that any activity where you
wear pants is not a sport or any
activity where alcohol enhances your
performance is not a sport and so I did
not like golf but that has changed and I
certainly about the sport alright put
the phone down next to the golf ball and
I want you to hit a shot and now I can
all analyze your swing no I'm not on the
course right now I'm in the the 19th
hole on the balcony oh yeah I'm starting
early I also I did some research and I
realized you made a cameo in a
Nickelback music video called Rockstar
did you yes
how did that happen that you were in a
Nickelback video you know that's a good
question I will say this nothing against
Nickelback I had never heard of
Nickelback prior to being asked their
Canadian crew my wife is Canadian I
think it was through her management I
don't know if they had the same
management company but I was asked
through them
my wife's management group
and I said why not you know I've never
been in a video before so I shot my
little scene in in Los Angeles and it
was something that I could scratch off
my bucket list
but yeah so that was kind of how all
came about and are they still there
still are they still relevant they get
brought up in a negative way it's it's
usually like people hate Nickelback and
then now and not because of your
appearance in the video but because like
imagine dragons has now taken the baton
from Nickelback as the most hated band
apparently so oh wow so if imagine
dragons does a video and calls you then
you might reconsider just just saying it
well maybe it's me
maybe they shouldn't call me that's the
reason why I'm nickel protection so
hated yeah next time I'm asked I'll
consult with you first Dan you tend to
know these things better than I do but
it was fun it was fun it was cute and
you know hey I did it
probably won't do it again you also were
involved in a basketball game back in
2010 with President Obama's now I think
it was his birthday and Carmelo was
there LeBron their magic Bill Russell
Dewayne Wade is that is that the guest
list there that you guys had a pickup
game yeah yeah no there were more
Chauncey Billups Eric Rose NOLA Battier
but yeah all those guys were there it
was President Obama's 49th birthday
it was crazy damn because we all met at
the White House and once we got there we
were you know bust over to an Air Force
Base and I guess a particular location
where the president played a lot of his
pickup games and basically it was really
funny he told us he said look before we
started playing he said you see all
those Secret Service around the court
you know they all have guns and they all
shoot on my command so what they broke
the group up
into four different teams and and I
think the last set of games
President Obama hit the game-winning
three on Derrick Rose and it was just it
was fitting it was perfect perfect
ending it was one of those things as a
basketball fan if you were a basketball
fan you were president you said I could
do anything like this is what I do for
my birthday and he did and I think he
enjoyed it I think we enjoyed it just as
much as he did and certainly one of one
of my most memorable moments that uh
that I was able to be a part of really
really special but but were you able to
put him on lockdown or because it's the
president you sort of have to let him
and it's his birthday I mean you got to
let him get a couple of jumpers in is
that what was going on oh yeah don't
make no mistake no one would he went to
the hole you know I was like it's like
the parting of the Red Sea you know it
was token defense okay you know you know
what it reminded me of it reminded me of
when I was in school at Duke and we're
in practice and we're messing up and
Coach K would grab the ball and say okay
you know what let me run the point and
so you know full-speed guys let's go and
like you can't really guard Coach K you
know so you know he's making a movie
comes down the paint it's just kind of
like okay since you brought up Duke you
know this is an interesting Duke team
because it doesn't feel like America is
turned on Duke at least not yet that we
still like we're fascinated with Zion
Williamson you know it's kind of
refreshing that this is a Duke team that
you tuned in and you may actually like
you know you had Tracy McGrady and
Scottie Pippen saying Zion should set it
down the rest of the season
what did you make of those comments for
obvious reasons ion and for those guys
they're RJ Barrett
its own ready stuff all the guys on the
team they're having fun
you know it's a great experience a great
time for them I think the beauty of the
college game and there's been a lot of
controversy for obvious reasons but you
know a program like Duke or Carolina or
Kansas or you know some of these
high-profile programs it's a chance for
you know for the country to fall in love
with these players it's a chance for
people to really get to know who's ion
Williamson is but in addition to that
it's just fun I mean those guys are
having fun they're enjoying themselves
they're having fun with one another
they're learning Coach K they're playing
in a great conference and so to deny
them that opportunity and I understand
where Scotty and Tracy are coming from
but you know I don't adhere to that I
think should play it out I think he'll
get better and continue to improve you
know all those guys I mean you know a
lot of Duke guys that we've had in
recent years have been one of done
players who've going on and played in
the NBA they all talk about how much fun
they enjoy it at college and how much
you know man it was just a great
experience for them and Zions going
through that now
and so so so you know I don't want him
to shut down you know I want him to play
and hopefully play into April but you
know I think I think just knowing what
he's experiencing what he's a part of
this will be something he'll always
remember for the rest of his life Grant
Hill star of a Nickelback music video
called rock star joining us at the Dan
Patrick show Michael Beasley checked
into the Lakers game last night he had
the wrong shorts on yet practice shorts
on have you ever had a teammate who had
a wardrobe malfunction something stupid
like that no I've never had a teammate
no and I did see that Michael Beasley
last night and he owned it you know he
quickly realized it and ran back to the
locker room so I do respect that but but
how does that happen grant yeah I don't
know you know honestly I don't know you
know I mean put it this way there are
certain people that you're not supplies
it happens to and I'll just leave it at
that
was there did did binoy Benjamin once
check into a game did he have shorts
backwards or you know I think he's
somebody who evolved to that category
yes I do remember I love the knobby
yes brother Dukey you did that once in
portland and i think it was a playoff
game he had his pants on backwards you
know he or he didn't have his jersey on
and so and so now i dunno i think i
played with material Green in Detroit
and I think there were times where he
was almost as a joke he knew he wasn't
gonna play so he would have his sweat
suit with nothing on underneath and it
was kind of like rolling the dice you
know it's good to talk to you oh let you
get back to your golf game and I would
take Charles over you right now just to
let you know if it was you against
Charles straight up in golf career yeah
you really do yes I would
yeah I respect that but I okay you know
there's a place to showcase this and
it's in Tahoe over the summer grant fu
oh I'll be there I'm working at beauty
this year yeah my golf buddy Vince
Carter was there last year we play a lot
together here in Orlando they played
last summer so I plan on being a that's
the plan
if you don't see you they're there if
you face like Berkeley one on one in
basketball yes I know right now oh yeah
okay what about could you beat Shaq
right now I saw Jack yesterday at the
studios
he is so big do you think Shaq was now
he's got to be to a 360 any solid like
he's been lifting weights yeah so he's
he's like 360 370 and we played together
in Phoenix in 2009 he was 320 330 and he
looks he looks bigger a lot bigger
there's there's nobody like him on the
face of the earth this era have been
scary he wasn't gonna go so pick and pop
all day but on that block oh he was a
load he was a look and here's the thing
I'm just gonna say this day I know she I
play you know he was a mean guy yeah if
he was a mean guy he would hurt people
he was that big and that strong that he
could have really hurt people and he can
take play all that tough-guy bravado and
all that was actually next person and
you know I found that out playing
whistle hey good luck with the golf game
and thanks for joining us is always
grant good to talk to you
Grant Hill hall-of-famer if you missed
any of our interviews this week from the
mercedes-amg man cave go to the Dan
Patrick show app where you can watch and
listen from inside the mercedes-amg man
cave mercedes-amg driving performance
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]